riyo's this summer so you deep in
training now yeah so after European
Championships last weekend I've had a
couple of days off and then yes back to
training six hours a day six days a week
and then it's the Olympic Games it's
kind of terrifying because you know you
get that training moment for four years
you have to train for that one moment
and doesn't matter if you're European
champion world champion Olympic champion
from before in that one moment on that
particular day you have six dives and if
you mess one of them up then it's over I
think you say on the Saros when you put
on the speedos hole if in them dude yeah
oh yeah like like quite often you get
doted on it tourneys I know when I can
revoke it you the seller McCartney is
designed the speedos now sadly she ran
out of material money and interests so
those of us meet up with now they sent
us a pair of the speedos and they really
are quite small no soy sauce going to
say how lovely
yeah they're still down but like they
are very small Tom well everything has
to stay in place obviously means if you
if you're spinning around the last thing
you want to do is something come out of
it so good and also when you hit the
water you don't want things you know
flapping about it simply because I mean
oh it hurts it so the closer you can
keep it all in the better really yeah
you're gonna ask me to put those on
okay it would look like a very ill
elephant but what I would what I'd only
be in Delhi but what if anything changes
and you're wearing those Oh I mean when
you're stood on the end of it have you
ever sit on the end of a 10 metre
platform so that that's probably the
last thing that will go through your
head is that I have anything about when
they give you the medal you're thinking
look at me
the meaning in the oh sorry
you a little bit more on the podium you
actually have like a foot on track seat
oh that's thought yeah is that why the
owner Jackson please yeah what I don't
think that's why they give them tracks
okay stay get a boner
there you go oh are you real extra Tony
Michael you know like that and then I
will his belly went in my mouth